while man of steel was a divisive film
many would agree that henry cavill made
for an excellent superman not only did
he look great in the famous costume he
also seemed to embody the character
perfectly as a result fans have begged
to see more of cavill as superman he's
popped up in other projects since like a
batman v superman at dawn of justice and
justice league but he's not had the
chance to lead another solo project yet
since man of steel came out in 2013
warner brothers has been silent
regarding whether we'll see caval suit
up as a last son of krypton ever again
even when superman appeared in the final
episode of peacemaker season 1 a
different actor slipped into caval's
iconic suits and his face was never
shown and when superman briefly appeared
in shazam cavill was nowhere in sight
either there's a good chance we'll never
see cavill as a man of steel ever again
but it's undeniable that the actor is
immensely talented in fact many fans
have been left wondering if caval might
jump ship to marvel some have even
speculated that he could appear as
captain britain at some point in the
future plus one artist has imagined what
the actor could look like as one of the
most iconic characters in all of marvel
comics and that's wolverine for years
hugh jackman was wolverine the x-men
franchise went through various
iterations but the one constant was that
you could always expect jackman to show
up and lay down the hurt now that disney
owns 20th century studios fans are
eagerly awaiting an announcement about
when we'll see a new wolverine actor
rise up and take the reins there's a lot
of talk about who could feasibly take on
such an iconic role and henry cavill's
name comes up from time to time
instagram artist roy ledger has even
taken it upon themselves to envision
what caval could theoretically look like
in the role and the result is pretty
epic whereas jackman's wolverine was
rough but reasonably put together
leger's version is positively feral
sporting the character's iconic
sideburns from the comics as well as an
incredible mask that jackman didn't wear
during his run it certainly seemed to
have won over fans as plenty of people
have commented voicing their support for
the artwork for instance one fan
enthused definitely the best fan art out
there ever since this rumor came out
tapping mr sheik
still others think caval would be better
suited for a different mutant with one
fan bluntly writing nope way too tall
and he's better for cyclops i think
regardless of his next role it's clear
that most fans just want to see cavill
appear in another superhero property
sooner rather than later it may be a
while before we get another wolverine
introduced on film marvel studios has
yet to announce any upcoming x-men
projects despite having the rights to
the characters there's no doubt that
when wolverine's time comes it will be
one of the most hotly sought-after roles
in hollywood the question then becomes
is caval the right actor for the job
whether wolverine makes his debut in a
movie or a disney plus original series
there are plenty of qualities cavall
could bring to the part that make him an
ideal choice for starters he's an
incredible actor as evidenced by a
litany of eclectic paths in the likes of
the witcher and mission impossible
fallout plus cavill has experience
playing both good guys and bad guys so
he could embody both the heroic and
anti-heroic qualities of the character
be their hero clock
be their monument be their angel
be anything they need you to be
whether or not caval would be a good fit
for the role really depends on what
iteration of wolverine the mcu goes with
in the comics wolverine is supposed to
be around five foot two or five foot
three cavall stands at six foot one so
he's quite a bit taller than the
character granted hugh jackman was also
taller than wolverine's suggested height
but the mcu might want to make their
next adaptation more accurate to the
comics there's also the question of
whether or not caval would have time to
join the mcu in such a major capacity
with his prominent role in netflix's the
witcher only time will tell but there's
no doubt that the mcu would benefit
greatly from kabul's presence
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]